So LibGDX provides us a with a way to
talk to the GPU without needing to
actually use OpenGL.
LibGDX also provides
us with a rectangular
area of the screen we can draw to.
On a mobile device that's
generally the entire screen.
Now we need to thing about how we're
going to position stuff on that screen.
We clearly need an x, y pair.
And the easiest way to position stuff is
by having the x value be the number of
pixels from the left edge of the screen,
and
have the y value be the number of
pixels from the bottom of the screen.
That's the approach we
are going to stick with for
the rest of this level, but
next level we'll start using
a much more flexible system
called an orthographic camera.